you've coached
45 national champions 106 big ten
champions
and eight olympic medalists which is
incredible
what is a common thread between them
and what are maybe some of the
fundamental differences
i think the common thread is that
they all had one of those two avenues
that we talked already
and because we intertwined them
so in a russian wrestling room they got
the same people
most the time in an american wrestling
room we had the same people
but when i was out recruiting at first i
recruited just
attitude but i needed more than that
i needed some genetics in that wrestling
room
to actually that hard work people
you know they could look and see wow
that execution that's unbelievable
but yet i can beat that guy after the
first minute
so you think you think the art the
the technique is genetics you're born
with it
you think it's not i think you're pop
and you're
you know your ability to move timing and
timing and
your quickness and your strength you
know the russians
they usually picked out
the people that can go into that sport
that was the old-fashioned sports school
but it's it's mostly like when you see
you walk into a russian wrestling room
you see him hitting skills techniques
you know you don't see him banging
against each other that much
but then when practice is over you might
not see a bunch of sprints
you might see him walk over to the uh
the ropes
and they drop down from the ceiling and
they'll jump up and
climb a rope boom boom boom and then
they come down
and then they don't jump right back on
they have three or four other guys go
and then they jump back on whereas i
probably made my guys climb them get
right back down climb them right back
again
but i also realized
that i had to have a mix of that what
was the role what was your role
i mean those guys looked up and dan
gable and
what was the role in helping these
athletes become their best these
national champions we had to first of
all prove that you were
knew what you were doing in terms of
technique or in terms of
everything everything they just you had
to be the first guy there and the last
guy to leave and you had to be the most
dedicated guy
even though they were the ones that's
trying to win the championships
uh you had to prove that you were going
to work just as hard as they were as a
coach
and what does that look like what so you
can see it when you you know when you
see it
well you you're there ahead of them yeah
and you're there
after they leave you know it's that's
it's that simple
i'm picking up after them and you're
analyzing them
you outwork them you out work them and
and you out thank them
and so you know use that type of
strategy and over time
when you prove it works because
some of my kids that were the best kids
in the world
really shouldn't have been a wrestler
i mean they weren't very coordinated
yeah but they worked so hard to develop
themselves
what was your role in that process i
mean that means pushing
kids to their limit if if you're not
going
but you can't push kids to their limit
and even when you push them to their
limit
that's not their limit because their
limits above and beyond that right i
mean
yeah coaches sometimes accidentally
don't
they lose kids yeah because of the heat
because of
hard work and all that and you gotta you
gotta know where to when to back off
you gotta read your athletes and by that
i mean
you to know him pretty well every once
in a while you make a little bit of
mistake but if you don't react right on
that mistake before it gets too far
then it's going to be a casualty and i
don't mean somebody dying
necessarily but maybe something that
could turn them off
or maybe something that can run them
away or maybe something that
wow that was close i maybe shouldn't
have pushed them that far
so you really have to be very educated
and
it's not just what you know it's what
you know about
them and i'm not talking about the team
i'm talking about each guy
individuals yeah yeah each person on the
team and you you know it
how you see it you know how because
you're the first one there you're the
last one to leave and
and you set in the uh environment with
them you're there
for in the morning for practice
sometimes you're there in the afternoon
for two or three hours
after practice you might have a a hot
room or
you might have a sauna or a steam or a
whirlpool and you get in there with them
and you listen
you know you're not just feeding out
information
you do that but you're taking in a lot
of that too
and i'm telling you when you get in an
atmosphere that they're relaxed
and they feel comfortable it's like a
massage
and that's after practice in one of
those areas that
people are around you you learn a lot i
mean you got a lot to learn as a coach
and when you get in that atmosphere when
all of a sudden you feel like
very comfortable words start flowing
and when those words flow
you take them in as a coach and there's
something
probably gonna be said that you can do
and act upon
that's gonna help certain situations
i've saved a couple kids lives for sure
that we're on the brink
you know sometimes performance is at
such a high level in a
high level atmosphere
that life and death is actually involved
and i don't mean pushing a kid to where
he just dies but i mean he might
feel himself as a failure and he may go
home and take his own life
you